er weiß wie man menschen für sich
einnimmt bleibt meine eltern laden sich
in interlaken kennen und er weiß worauf
die presse ab fährt dann ist die schweiz
nicht gäbe gäbe es auch kein hugh
jackman der könig der charmeur
er hat kommunikation studiert spielt
gekonnt mit klischees
ich bin meistens pünktlich ich liebe
schokolade und was war noch die andere
qualität sind sie reich das ist verrat
ich will natürlich zu recht
hugh jackman kann viel mehr als nur die
krallen ausfahren als action held
im epos australia ließ er als liebhaber
von nicole kidman die frauenherzen
schmelzen
für die rolle des john baillie in
musical les miserables gewann er dieses
jahr singend den golden globe in seinem
aktuellen thriller prisoners spielt er
einen mann dessen tochter entführt wird
der verzweifelte vater rastet aus als
der verdächtige mangels beweisen frei
kommt er nimmt das gesetz selbst in die
hand und greift zu drastischen mitteln
eine anspruchsvolle rolle von hugh
jackmann oscar verdächtig gespielt der
beste beweis für seine wandelbarkeit als
schauspieler versucht man immer keinen
stempel aufgedrückt zu bekommen
journalisten tut das aber dauert er sagt
ich bin ein familienmensch oder ein
action held oder was auch immer
mein leben ist nicht so ich sehe das
leben auch nicht aufgeteilt in weiblich
oder männlich
für mich ist wichtiger was uns verbindet
als was uns trennt
der 44 jährige australier ist ein großer
verführer als tänzer sänger und
schauspieler
doch es sind andere qualitäten die für
ihn einen echten mann aus machen
ehrlichkeit sei die fähigkeit sich
selbst zu durchschauen und bescheiden
bleiben
ich denke der unterschied zwischen einem
jungen und einem mann ist die erkenntnis
dass sich die welt nicht nur um einen
selbst riet der von der natur beschenkte
star bringt seine fans auf hochtouren
im internet wimmelt es von bildern auch
zum sexiest man alive wurde er gekühlt
eine ehre die er mit ironie begegnet wie
meine frau damit umgeht
sie sagt klar wenn sonst hätt' ich
heiraten soll sie geht echt cooler mit
dem heft komma wenn sie mir gefiel den
müll runterzubringen ich sage meine
hände sind dafür zu wertvoll er ist seit
17 jahren mit der australischen
schauspielerin deborah lee furness
verheiratet und hat zwei adoptivkinder
das sensibilisiert ihn für die neue
rolle im film präsenz in der er als
vater jede kontrolle verliert wie weit
wird er hugh jackman für seine kinder
gehen
ich weiß dass ich weit gehen würde
ich würde gerne glauben dass ich sie
beschützen könnte ohne andere personen
zu verletzen
die wahrheit ist dass solche
diskussionen in einer solchen situation
bedeutungslos sind weil es kein kopf
entscheid ist sondern aus dem bauch
heraus kommt musste der frauenschwarm
auf ein schweizer von die verzichten
zugunsten seines waschbrettbauch
ich glaube nicht dass da noch einer ist
hallo wo bist du hin kommt man wenn ich
einen waschbrettbauch haben muss für
einen film dann trainiere ich mir an
kann aber glauben sie mir sonst sie ich
gutes essen